in the emergency department all the time
i'm like i'm sorry your bone is
fractured and they're like i'm just glad
it's not broken and i'm like no that's
actually the exact same thing hey i'm dr
j max slaughter and i'll be answering
your questions from twitter today this
is injury support
[Music]
this is from sid 1998 how many
concussions is too many concussions
asking for a friend i'm thinking by the
way that you delivered that you're
actually asking for yourself a
concussion is the state that you are in
mentally temporarily after a mild
traumatic brain injury the symptoms
range from decreased attention span
lethargy or feeling really tired feeling
a little confused severe headaches light
sensitivity and nausea the feeling that
you're going to throw up so there's a
very wide range of symptoms that you can
have with this condition it depends on
the type of concussion how big was the
concussion and also how severe were your
symptoms afterwards i'd say the most
feared outcome of multiple concussions
is something called cte or chronic
traumatic encephalopathy people with
chronic traumatic encephalopathy a lot
of them are boxers or football players
who get repetitive head traumas end up
with very severe issues long term like
dementia really bad headaches behavioral
changes aggressiveness and suicidality
there was one study that showed that
about 17 concussions was the average of
a lot of people who had chronic
traumatic encephalopathy but the answer
is avoid concussions at all costs from
holohona
what happens when you break a bone and
don't set it back correctly it depends
on where the fracture is how severe the
fracture is and how well aligned the
bones are i hear about people you know
really hurting themselves a bonus you
know facing in the wrong direction
they're like i'm gonna be a man and just
fix it on the spot don't do that you
have no idea what injury that looks like
under the surface of your skin it may
not need any realignment at all so do
not try to set your bones back do not
try to put your dislocations back in
place please don't do this at home also
is it going into a joint a joint is
basically where two bones meet we have
joints all over our body and if a
fracture goes into that joint it's more
important for that fracture to heal very
very well and for everything to be
aligned because you can imagine if there
are well like bone fragments inside the
joint and then you try to move your
extremity and it can be very painful and
it can lead to a significant amount of
arthritis long term so go see an
orthopedic doctor don't try to fix your
own brakes at home that's my answer
from this isn't fabia i think i've
dislocated my shoulder help how do i
know if i've dislocated it first of all
you'll know if you have a dislocation or
a fracture because it'll be one of the
most painful things that you've ever
experienced in your life and these are
things that need to be seen by doctors
so don't try to diagnose yourself at
home using dr google and try to pop
things back in place but i will say in
the emergency department before i get
x-rays if somebody thinks that there's a
shoulder dislocation i will have them
take the arm that's affected and try to
touch the other shoulder so if somebody
has a shoulder dislocation they're not
gonna be able to do it so that's one of
the things i do after i pop a shoulder
back in place which is awesomely
satisfying i must say we check to see if
it's back in place before x-rays by
seeing if that arm goes up to the
contralateral shoulder that is the
opposite shoulder this question is from
amseries how does one know when stitches
are needed asking for a friend it's a
difficult answer there are certain
stitches that we put in place because
it's just gonna have a better cosmetic
outcome that is it's gonna look better
long-term but there are other stitches
real real deep lacerations that we
absolutely need to stitch up for
instance if it gets deep enough to go to
this layer called the fascia now fascia
is like really dense tissue and that
kind of holds certain structures in
place think of it as like layering like
layering of a cake or something like
that so that particular layer called the
fascial plane that separates those two
areas a lot of times needs to be
repaired and so we'll put stitches in
there to bring that back together and if
you don't the muscles or structures that
are under that fascial plane can kind of
herniate through and they'll cause you
some issues also i should mention there
are absorbable sutures and there are
non-absorbable sutures there are certain
stitches that we don't want your body to
absorb for instance if there's a tendon
that's been cut and we're repairing that
a lot of times we're going to use a
non-absorbable suture we want that
stitch to stay in place because it takes
a long time for tendons to heal fully
okay there are other areas of the body
or certain situations where we want the
stitches to dissolve and those
dissolvable stitches or absorbable
stitches are made out of either
synthetic polymers or they're made out
of animal intestines so come to the
emergency department and we might stitch
you up with animal intestines all right
this next question is from justin
wolfson i broke my femur in a car wreck
and i have some cues by the way this is
a terribly painful experience so justin
wolf said my heart goes out to you
brother how much force does it take to
break a friggin femur how do they get
that rod in there don't i need that
missing bone marrow and how do these
heal before this surgery existed it's a
lot of force the answer is about 4 000
newtons of force 4000 newtons is about
equivalent to 900 pounds here on on
earth's gravity so you can think of like
a sea lion or a really big moose that is
the amount of force that it takes you
think about surgeries in general is
being a very like gentle
precise
operation orthopedic surgeries are not
gentle they're putting force in there
they're using muscles because it
genuinely requires a significant amount
of force to get these surgeries done and
to put bones back in place to get
that rod into your femur they basically
have to align it where the cavity is
where your bone marrow is okay and it's
called an intra medullary rod they align
it and they take a big ol hammer and
they go
until it's all the way in there so it is
violent and it takes a lot of force and
it's impressive to see don't i need that
missing bone mirror nah you really don't
i mean you have bone marrow throughout
the rest of your bones you'll be fine
last question how did these heal before
the surgery existed and the answer is
very very poorly they probably didn't
heal very well at all that person maybe
never walked again if you were in a car
accident in the 1500s all right the next
question is from kieran kalan why are
shin splints
so painful so shin splints are known as
median tibial stress syndrome and that's
basically where there's inflammation of
a lot of the structures that are there
around your tibia your tibia is this
long bone here in your lower extremity
right next to your fibula which is the
skinnier bone that runs along the side
runners always get these shin splints a
lot of cheerleaders get shin splints and
these can be very very painful now
here's the thing though that pain should
resolve with rest definitely get seen if
that pain doesn't resolve with cessation
of that activity this is from london
hearts one what is a defibrillator do i
have to be trained to use one so a
defibrillator is basically a device that
administers electricity to the heart the
bottom part of your heart are the
ventricles all right and when the heart
naturally does its thing the top part
squeezes first the atria squeeze the
bottom part squeezes afterwards boom
boom boom boom so if the bottom part of
the heart isn't given a good a hearty
squeeze there see what i did there with
hardy that was a total accident you're
not going to get blood flow to your
brain or to your extremities and you're
going to start dying when you go into
these dangerous heart rhythms you get
electricity of the heart as soon as
possible ask for an aed or automatic
external defibrillator don't be worried
you can do this you can save someone's
life call for 9-1-1 as well because
they're trained they're going to know
what to do especially in the field but
if you can get an aed it'll tell you to
put these pads on the chest and and on
the back and you're going to basically
sandwich the heart and that's going to
make it to where the electricity runs
between the two pads if you don't have
access to an aed and or you're a
professional this is what you're gonna
need this is called a life pack
so this bad boy is over fifty thousand
dollars worth of machine what we do is
we hook this up to somebody's chest when
it's hooked up you'll be able to see the
rhythm that the heart is in you'll be
able to tell is that person in
ventricular fibrillation or ventricular
tachycardia and then we can determine do
they need defibrillation or do they need
something called synchronized
cardioversion this will basically take
someone who is inevitably going to die
and bring them back to life very rapidly
this is one of the best inventions that
modern medicine has to be honest so this
thing's pretty amazing
the next question is from pt works and
the question is what is the most serious
or painful injury you've ever
encountered i mean the most serious
injuries are the ones where the patient
comes in dead when you classify traumas
based on like what hit what so you'll
say like motor vehicle versus like
bicyclist or train versus pedestrian you
can imagine that train versus pedestrian
was the most serious thing that i've
seen in the emergency department the guy
not to gross you out but had a traumatic
amputation that is his arm was ripped
off from the force and he was already
dead
by the time he came in and so that is
the most serious injury that i've seen
some of the most painful injuries that i
see actually are ones that cause
ischemia now ischemia is lack of blood
flow to tissue or lack of oxygen so if
there is an injury that either like rips
the blood vessel apart or causes a
certain abnormality that would decrease
the blood flow to a certain area that is
exquisitely painful hopefully you never
have to experience something like that
in your lifetime and this is from
mediocentro is an achilles tendon terror
the worst injury an athlete can get so i
should tell you what an achilles tendon
is
your achilles tendon is this tendon back
here that attaches your calf basically
to your foot and allows you to flex your
foot and so when this pops you can't do
this anymore and that's pretty important
for running walking jumping etc this is
a shocking
morbid injury but i would argue this is
not the worst injury that an athlete can
sustain because think about a spinal
cord injury man you get a cervical spine
injury that is you essentially like
fracture the bones here in the neck and
it ends up pushing on your spinal cord
and you may never be able to walk
use your arms or legs i think paralysis
that's the worst injury that an athlete
can get all right this next question is
from let's do med legal is it okay to
treat my dog bite injury at home
absolutely not these are at very very
high risk for infection you need
antibiotics also when was the last time
you got a tetanus shot also rabies
that's a problem chances are pretty low
right but if you get it
guess how fatal it is
a hundred percent now if they can catch
the animal and it's a stray animal
that's different what they do is they
watch the dog for multiple days make
sure they don't exhibit any signs of
rabies if they don't then it's fine you
don't have to get all your rabies shots
and stuff like that but if it's some
rando dog that [ __ ] you ran away and
you're never going to see it again you
need to get your rabies shot you also
want to get x-rays to make sure there
isn't a big old chunk of bone under the
surface there because again very very
high risk for infection from 41 sheisty
what is tommy john surgery let me get my
little arm model right here this is your
humerus all right this is your alma
right here and this is your
radius and what happens in people that
require tommy john surgery is they end
up having a rupture of this tendon
called the ulnar collateral ligament the
older collateral ligament connects um
the humerus which is this bone here
right down to the ulna and if you are
throwing overhead
all day every day for years and years
and years you put yourself a risk
especially if you're putting a ton of
force behind it you're throwing
fastballs and once that thing pops
you're going to have a lot of pain
when you're throwing it's going to be
really tender over that area where the
ligament naturally is so what do they do
during a tommy john surgery they end up
taking a tendon to fix your ligament
they'll either take a tendon from your
forearm your hamstrings or your foot and
they will reconnect those bones to kind
of stabilize that area on the medial
aspect of your elbow and you wonder
do you not need the tendon that they're
taking out from the other area of your
body and the answer is no not really
you're gonna do fine without it
p1p31150 i have no idea what that stands
for but how do you know if you have a
broken rib asking for a friend it's
always asking for a friend it's going to
be very painful if it hurts a lot or
you're having any difficulty breathing
you absolutely need to be seen because
you can have pain on one side and you
think oh it's just a broken rib whatever
they don't do surgery on that which is
true but what can happen is that rib if
that fractures and pokes your lung you
can pop a lung you can have a collapsed
lung if you get air in your thoracic
cavity that's outside of your lung it
can compress your lung
to the point where one you have
difficulty breathing and two you can put
so much pressure in the thoracic cavity
that you can cut off blood supply to the
heart you can squeeze the blood vessels
clothes that are responsible for getting
blood back to the heart you can imagine
it's only a matter of time before you
die if you're not getting blood flow to
your heart because if you don't get
blood flow to your heart you don't get
blood flow to the rest of your body so
if you think you have a rib fracture get
seen it might be more serious than you
think next question is how to treat
cooking oil burn i think i hate scars
that was a quote that was a quote i
didn't the answer is you treat a cooking
oil burn by getting seen in person
unfortunately you do need to get seen
this isn't something you should be
treating at home you have multiple
different depths of injuries with burns
they pretty much all need some sort of
antibiotic cream to put on there now
neosporin does work really well for a
burn especially if it just looks like
it's a sunburn and there's no bubbling
or anything that's probably gonna be a
superficial thickness burner first
degree burn but when you start getting
into those deeper burns when it's
bubbling up on the surface go see a
doctor to determine what depth of injury
it is and then long term depending on
where the burn is you may end up needing
the skin graft which is where they take
skin somewhere else in the body and then
we attach it to the area where the burn
is because our skin provides a very
important role
it one makes sure that we don't lose a
lot of water to our environment but the
skin also protects you against infection
so they're very very high risk for
infections also if the burn is over
a joint you can get scarring to kind of
resist your normal movement of the elbow
and and you may develop contractures and
they may need to get essentially
released surgically so go see a doctor
especially if it is bubbling or turning
a whitish color from straw hat ruby
what's the difference between a sprain
and a strain a sprain is when you have
an injury
to your ligaments ligaments
directly connect
bone
to bone tendons
are affected when you have a
strain
i said it wrong and tendons connect
muscle to bone and how do you kind of
know the difference between the two it's
difficult to say because both of them
are very painful but one of the big
differences is that muscle
strains can end up having a lot of like
cramping associated with the muscles now
that technically can happen with sprains
as well just a little less likely and
you can have limited movement
around that joint that's affected now
that's with the strain with a sprain you
won't have as much muscle spasm and you
may have more movement at that joint
because the ligament that was there kind
of stabilizing and holding it in place
is injured stretched maybe totally torn
and so you may be able to move it more
than you could before you could have
instability of that joint so that's the
difference between a sprain and a string
from luxon [ __ ] can you break your
funny bone not a rhetorical question i
really slam that [ __ ] on a changing
room locker the funny bone can be a very
painful injury and it's usually very
temporary but what happens is you have
an ulnar nerve you have this big old
nerve right on the medial aspect the
middle side of your elbow and that nerve
is responsible for your ability to feel
there and so that's why when you hit it
your fingers might kind of like tense up
and you get this really weird tingling
sensation all the way down your hand so
no you can't break your funny bone but
it can hurt a lot all right that's all
for now hope you guys learned something
today i'm dr j maxx signing off